welcome to our honored guest dr. Mambo
Noguchi and to all of you I'm Paula
kavitha's chair of the women's faculty
forum and we are co-sponsoring this
event with the colloquium on violence
intervention and agency co-organized by
Professor Kathryn panter brick ELISA
Lombard and graduate student alia
subroutine the colloquium is also
sponsored by the Macmillan Center for
International in aerial studies gender
violence is something that most of us
know too well when I was a young girl I
had a friend who went on to marry and
moved away one day I learned that she
had been shot and killed by her abusive
husband after she had made the break to
separate from him leaving three children
the story of domestic violence occurs
every 11 minutes over all over the globe
recently the American Association of
universities did a survey on sexual
assault and misconduct for 27
universities and the results of that
survey highlighted the problem that
exists on campus and actually that has
existed for a long time but we're doing
more about it than we ever did before
dr. Mambo noguchi is at the forefront of
efforts to stem and stop violence
against women she is executive director
of UN Women so it's a real privilege to
have her here today in three weeks
there'll be a major campaign to end
violence that will begin the UN
initiative is coined orange the world
orange represents a future free from
violence thus orange is a 3 theme of our
event for today
so after the event we have a luncheon
reception upstairs everyone is welcome
to come please stay but if you can't
stay feel free to get a sandwich and
take it with you so I'd like to now
introduce Catherine panter brick who is
professor of anthropology health global
affairs and master of morris college who
will introduce dr. Mambo new cuca
welcome so good afternoon is the really
very great pleasure for me to introduce
United Nations under secretary-general
and executive director of UN Women dr.
lambourn gorkha and I want to tell you a
little bit about her career she's
devoted the whole of her career to
issues of women's rights and justice
she's worked in government and civil
society and with the private sector and
she's was actively involved in a
struggle to end apartheid in her home
country of South Africa she served as
deputy president of south africa from
2005 2 2008 where she oversaw programs
to make the economy surge and eliminate
poverty especially for women before that
she served six years of ministry of
minerals as the minister of minerals and
energy in three years as deputy minister
in the Department of Trade and Industry
she was also a member of parliament as
part of south africa's first democratic
government and i'm proud to say that dr.
mula mula mula has began her career as a
teacher in her international career as a
coordinator for the world YWCA in Geneva
where she set up programs for young
women she is a founder of the home lambo
Foundation which supports leadership and
education she's a trustee of the Mandela
Rhodes foundation she's a long-term
champion of human rights and women's
rights affiliated with several
organization dedicated to education
woman answered Powerman and gender
equality she holds a pH
d in education and technology from the
university of warwick united kingdom and
it's my very great pleasure to ask you
to join me to welcome Under Secretary
General and executive director un women
to the podium today thank you very much
don't worry I'm not going to use and
thank you so much for this opportunity
and I'd like to thank a Yale University
for hosting the circular come on
violence intervention and agency a
special thanks to Professor Catherine
Ponte brick for really embracing us as
young women and making sure that we can
meet in this fashion thank you to dr.
Paula cavitus thank you to Louisa
Lombard and thank you to Aaliyah sejoon
for arranging today and we just
recognized that we with aaliyah we
actually met years ago when she was
doing undergrad in South Africa is a
rose Mandela scholar it's wonderful to
see you again and of course my fellow
panelist Gary thank you so much also we
normally meet in places like this you
could not have picked a more critical
topic and subject and at a critical in a
strategic time global violence against
women and girls is one of the most
pervasive violations of human rights of
our time it is everywhere it permeates
every society class race geographical
area age group and in fact last year the
world health organization called it a
global pandemic and a public health
crisis
Adrian women we tend to use the
statistics that is generated by the
World Health Organization's because it
tends to be more reliable because they
in that profession however cars are able
to determine the extent of the violence
and in the injuries that the women
suffer psychologically and physically
but also it is one place where women
confide and are able to talk in depth
about their experiences and in for many
women it is the only place where they
can see someone in the absence of the
perpetrator so they asked that their
data tends to be quite a reliable and it
is that data that has highlighted to us
that one out of three women globally
lives with some form of violence the
kinds of violence that we are talking
about include rape the trafficking of
women sextortion which impacts lots of
women who are looking for services when
they are desperate such as migrants
refugees and sometimes in public service
it involves a girls in some countries
where this a female genital mutilation
forced in early marriages students say
on campus the elderly especially widows
and of course we've also seen the
increase a of online a bullying which
drives some young people both boys and
girls air to commit suicide in some
cases we also of course all familiar
with domestic violence in many of our
communities and homes we see violence
also in areas a of conflict anything
from safe sex slavery in the capturing
of women by warring faction and using
women literally as goods that say the
exchange butter and sell in many
countries where there is
a violence sometimes it is more
dangerous to be a woman than to be a
soldier because women unarmed and I'm
not in combat and when violence is
unleashed on them they are relatively
unable to defend themselves in many
cases and in many countries the manner
in which we have responded to violence
against women has been slow and has not
always seen the crisis that the world is
facing but thankfully now there's a
really strong attraction and focus in as
well as their coordinates coordinated
efforts to address the issue of violence
against women then our ability to
violence is not primarily a factor of
poverty education sexual orientation
disability status ethnicity or
geographic location although each of
those aspects can intersect to further
diminish status and increase risk it is
truly a warring a universal a phenomenon
the resins that is it amazed that thirty
five percent of women worldwide have
experienced a violence in some countries
the figure is as high as seventy percent
on all of all women killed globally in
2012 almost half were killed by intimate
partners of family members and it's a
little also contradiction to talk about
intimacy and killing in the same
sentence but the percentage is so high
it truly makes a home a frightening
place for many women not a place of
comfort and refuge an estimated 183
million girls and women have experienced
some form of genital mutilation or
cutting 250 million alive women alive
today we married before the age of 15
against their world child brides are
less able to negotiate
safe sex they are available to early
pregnancy and of course they are exposed
to maternal and infant deaths as well as
sexually transmitted infections
including HIV and AIDS in 2014 wh 0 said
that one in 17 older adults reported
abuse in most parts of the world and
it's important also for us to consider
that the origins of violence like deeply
rooted in gender equality and
discrimination as well as cultural and
social norms and practices the violence
against women becomes made for the most
dehumanizing form of discrimination
against women which is a buildup of all
other suttles and forms of
discrimination that we live with but the
important thing also for us to notice
that violence against women and men
should not be inevitable it is not
normal it is not acceptable it is not
excusable and I think that is why i was
sitting here because we wanted to do
something we want to help or were
already doing something in about it what
is also important is the topic today
suggests is our coordinated efforts
because this is truly in a universal
phenomena and we have a lot to learn
from from each other both from what
works and what doesn't work just some of
the examples of a interventions that we
think are worthy of a noting we
emphasized in un women the importance of
protection so that we avoid and reduce
the number of women and girls who will
ever experience a violence against them
protective factors include a strong
human rights culture and it's zero
tolerance for any form of discrimination
and prejudice towards women and girls it
also
a requires leaders and those in
authority never to send mixed messages
it also emphasizes the importance of
education especially the education that
emphasizes the importance of rights and
respect of all people in the areas where
many girls may drop out of school it is
also important to emphasize the
importance of girls completing secondary
education because girls who drop out of
school early are most likely to be
exposed to hash violence it requires
also access to economic resources and
opportunities including credit access to
property and land and of course it also
requires us to pay attention to social
norms that promote gender equality in
many countries we have seen that
notwithstanding that many countries
passed laws that are progressive they
entrench a equality in constitutions and
laws but they still allow customary laws
that are harmful to that is harmful to
women and girls to exist side by side
with good law and in many cases the
customary law is what it dominates and
the impact and the value of the
progressive loss is therefore diminished
in the study of evaluating 20 years of
implementing the Beijing platform of
action that was one of the striking
features and in many cases when we talk
to leaders in different countries there
is always this oh you know culture there
is nothing we can do about it actually
we cannot say we can't do anything about
culture when it is harmful and say we
also stand for Human Rights inequality
and for in the context of the United
Nations we're all members of the UN vote
for Human Rights supports the UN Charter
it is a contradiction in terms tolerate
cultural practices that are harmful and
at the same time be a community in a
community of nations that recognizes the
rights of all people but we also
recognize that the causes of
gender-based violence
a complex so the approach also needs to
be comprehensive it requires a work to
start at home and to be consistent at
school at the workplace in religious and
cultural societies and bodies it also
requires a constant collection of data
so that we can check both the the
impacts and the frequency and the
changes that we experience something
that we have not been good at in many
countries which happily now we are
beginning to do more and more it also
requires us to focus both on prevention
and stopping recurrences it also means
that in all the countries a civil
society government and private sectors
must work together it also requires
legal and policies of the countries that
are meant to address violence against
women to be implemented intensely we
have seen that in countries where all of
these actually being presented at the
same time we begin to see change we
cannot say at this point in time that
we've had countries that are shining
example in winning in the fights against
violence against women sadly but we can
actually say that we do see change in
behavior and pattern when this
comprehensive package of intervention is
being presented legislation for us at
the United Nations is very important
because we work we are an
inter-governmental body and one thing
that governments have got is legislation
and also legislation has an an impact in
it affects millions of people in a
country just by a stroke of a pen
the lives of people can become worse or
better in a community in a country we
know now that at least 119 countries
have passed legislation and laws that
criminalize domestic violence that is in
the last 20 years 125 have laws on
sexual harassment and 52 have laws on
marital rape that is out of about 192
countries and a few territory so we do
not have a universal application of
these laws they're still countries that
we still need air to deal with globally
139 constitutions now include guarantees
of gender equality but in some of those
countries with this good constitution
you still have customary law that works
against the Constitution and in some
ways the perpetrators are also not
brought into good not withstanding that
there's a constitution that guarantees
equality in women have equal rights in
now hundred and fifty-nine 115 countries
to own property in in 19 three countries
women are able to have a cual
inheritance rights these are important
because these are some of the triggers
of violence against women without these
rights in many countries women become
vulnerable countries have also repealed
laws in adopted new legislative
framework to promote gender equality and
address violence against women and girls
a recent Welbeck's World Bank study of
143 economies found it 122 countries
still hit at least one legal difference
in how men and women were treated with
some impacts on the economic well-being
of a of the men or the women that
includes laws that make it impossible
for a women to independently up a obtain
an ID in the results there are many
women who actually do not have ideas and
countries because their partners say no
to them
having an ID also those laws include
loss that tell forbid women to access
credit and in some countries they
determine the jobs that women can and
cannot do so as you could see it is
quite a lot of angles that we need to
consider when you are fighting violence
against women because all of these
conditions put together creates a
fertile ground for women's rights to be
violated and in many cases that that
includes a physical as well as emotional
violence we work across the world we try
to create a common platform so that you
can work together which is why we're
wearing orange air today because this is
one of the campaign's that we are using
to promote awareness discussion
engagement exchange of experiences on
what we can do to end violence against
women this campaign which is 16 days of
no violence against women starts on the
twenty fifth of November up to the tenth
of December and throughout the world a
different activities are undertaken by
stakeholders as well as by by
individuals who will engage in
activities that are meant to highlight
their contribution as well as a
possibilities of what we could do to
address a violence against women we and
women emphasizes the importance of a
emphasizing prevention and will soon
produce a a tool kit together with al Oh
undp unesco univ a double h 0 which we
hope will assist many of you to
undertake activities that address the
issue of protection let me also just
quickly highlight the fact that the
world has just adopt
the sustainable development goals and
these goals bind all the countries they
are not for developing countries or for
developed countries there are 17 goals
and one of the goals a is focused on
gender equality the gender equality gold
focuses on ending our form of
discrimination against women and for us
is you and women and I hopefully for ye
we will be working together to ensure
that all of these countries that still
have India statutes legislation that
discriminate and oppress women in
different way and in many cases led to
some form of violence will be no more by
2030 when we finish implementing the
sustainable development goals it focuses
also on ending violence and against
women and it gives comprehensive
indicators on what we should do in order
to address a death goal it focuses also
on a provision of services to address
sexual as well as reproductive rights
something we did not think we're going
to get because member states can really
push back on that issue so we're quite
glad to get that in the in goal number 5
it also focuses the only a repressed
equal representation of women in
decision-making bodies especially in
political as well as in economic bodies
it focuses on recognizing reducing and
distributing unpaid care work it also
focus on ending a harmful practices that
impact on women and girls and it
specifically cites child marriages and
female genital mutilation if you
consider this goal and all the other
goals in which we have folks some form
of focus on women and girls you consider
the what we have in the Beijing platform
the unfinished business of the me Liam
development balls we've got a lot of
scope of the things that we need and can
do together to push the agenda forward
that is why we have been bold as you and
women to say between 25
student 2013 we truly should aim to
achieve substantive equality but we need
to pick on the on the on the only
winners on the initiatives and action
that we could all handle together in
order to push the agenda forward amongst
those for instance we would like to call
for a global an effective coalition to
of course to end violence against women
for equal pay for recognizing in
implementing programs that address and
paid a a que work because these are some
of the justices that okay almost in
every country whether we are each at a
poor country violence as a problem where
there are riches in a poor country
unpaid care work that impacts on women
in motherhood texts the u.s. is probably
one of the countries that has a big
challenge in debt this is a problem in
every country in the world also we could
address the issue of unequal pay in fact
the global average of the amount paid to
women compared to that of a man doing
the same work is 20 women are paid
twenty four percent less and again there
we can galvanize a global support but of
course at the same time allow for
national variety when we undertake these
activities across the world we think
that we have an opportunity to move the
agenda substantively forward we also
recognize the important role of men and
boys and I want to say something because
there will talk about it but it is a
luxury for us to think that day we will
be able to achieve the kinds of ambition
goals and the agenda that we have
without engaging men and boys and young
people so that for us as you H Adrian
women is a critical constituency the
religious constituency the cultural
constituency the academia and the media
these are critical constituency for us
so i would like to leave yael with some
asks
I of course specifically to violence
against women I think your challenges
that you still have on campuses it's
important to address them and address
them effectively but it's also important
for you to share your experiences
especially where you've got best
practice so that you are able to
contribute to the body of knowledge to
the extent that you a premium
institution and teach that teaches law
it's important that you produce lawyers
that are more in tune in a more schooled
in understanding issues of violence
against women we have found that in many
countries there are law schools where
the issue does not even arise law
students graduate without even knowing
that there's a problem of violence
against women in the countries that they
live in including my own country South
Africa where the problem is so high my
daughter my daughter in law graduated
about four years ago she said mama I did
not even know that the problem was so
big until I left University so we think
that you may play a role in mobilizing
other universities around the world to
take this issue seriously we would like
to invite you to actively participate in
the campaign for equal pay and I saw
that in the statistics you are one of
the countries that has got a smaller gap
closed it is so close it's so close we
become number one and of course we would
like you to look at how you could
support the domestication of the
sustainable development goals so that
both in the US and elsewhere you can
help the countries adopt the goals and
look at how you could make sure that the
goals work for the citizens of all
countries and of course we are the first
generation with a real possibility to
achieve significantly on gender equality
we are the first generation with a
significant possibility to end poverty
we are the last generation that can do
something significant on climate because
if you do not do it we live the next
general
open to many disasters so it's an
exciting time for us to live in but a
lot of responsibilities and is upon us
but if we coordinate and we work
together there's a lot that we can do
and many of these things when we are
able to do them well they will truly
benefit women they are quality of life
and impact on the reduction of violence
against women and the structures that
make violence against women the current
as well as a everyday occurrence in many
communities thank you thank you so much
dr. mahamadu cuca so we would like to
take some questions and answers from the
audience but first I would like to thank
you for for this for the focus on
protection and the focus on prevention
and the phrase it takes lots of angles
because it does and we're all here to do
that for the very clear goals you've
expressed and for the few asks that you
have of Yale University we're on our way
to President salivates office afterwards
I hope to discuss this but and before we
have questions from the audience because
this is a unique opportunity to have the
executive directive un women with us
today I'd like just to bring a quick our
conversation quickly include our other
panelists in particular dr. gary becker
who is the international director and
the founder of Rome and 0 which is an
organization international I NGO that
has worked for two decades in 20
different countries to involve men to
promote gender equity and end violence
against women and that I have countered
there's about 20 men in the room today
so thank you for coming so my question
to you dr. Barker is what does it take
to get men to advocate for women and how
do we get this to scale um first thanks
emslie for those comments and I think
one of the first things we need to do is
to get well more than 20 men in a room
as a good start and to break the silence
we heard some of the numbers on just how
many women experience violence in their
lifetime
we know that about thirty percent of men
globally will use physical violence
against a woman at some point in their
lives but that number varies hugely by
setting in some countries it's as many
as seventy percent in some countries
it's as low as twenty percent the point
is even in the countries where it's the
highest there's at least a majority or a
sizeable minority of men who don't use
violence but we're those of us who don't
use it and don't believe it are pretty
silent about it you don't see a lot of
men sort of spontaneously go into a bar
go into a chat room on their phone and
go I want to talk about violence against
women those of us who don't use it and
are bored by it kind of hope that we can
talk about anything but that topic we've
sometimes experienced the violence at
the hands of other men we kind of think
we want to do anything we can to stay
out of that but I think part of the main
thing we need to do is to get men to in
structured and unstructured ways to be
part of raising our voices around it not
instead of women but with because
sometimes you invite a couple of min in
and we do take a space over we have to
be careful that's not what we mean but
being part of spaces as well to make the
change happen I think one very concrete
way is to talk about the laws that you
brought up most countries and one of the
successes of the women's rights movement
in the last 40 years has been that
there's almost there's what three or
four countries in the world where it is
still legal on the books for a man to
use violence against his spouse or his
wife the vast majority of the world's
countries whether they believe it or not
have signed on to these laws but the
issue of course as we know and that's
whether Yale University which I
understand is that its own challenges
and sexual assault recently it's how we
take the really good policies and laws
that we often have in place and really
make them happen kind of one judge one
nurse one social worker one outreach
worker at a time to make sure that
really the laws and policies that are
there to create this culture of zero
tolerance that you mentioned really
comes to life and we need lots of men
there we know that a lot of those
gatekeepers those who control access to
services and whether cases of violence
are taken seriously are men so we
certainly need to get into their heads
that need to take this seriously think
the other thing we need to do is to go
beyond there's a lot of one-off
discussions with men
about the topic whether it's the
45-minute orientation given to freshmen
when they come on campus whether it's
the one time of year where we march
around the white ribbon campaign whether
it's one conversation with young men you
know on a soccer field or something we
often assume that if we talk to you for
10 minutes you've got it you'll sort of
bind a gender equality for the rest of
your life we don't have to do anything
else you won't use violence we've got to
be a lot more thoughtful and critical
about what it is that drives violence
and how do we use that data than to
design interventions we know from a 15
country study that we've done and other
data supports this that at the
individual level men who witnessed
violence growing up so those who
witnessed it against their mother by
another man are about three times more
likely to use violence later on against
a female partner women who witnessed
that growing up were more likely to be
in a violent relationship later on boys
who are victims of bullying or other
kinds of fights or about two and a half
times more likely to use partner
violence later on what that tells us is
that it's not as if the risk of using
violence kind of falls evenly in a
population there are some individuals
who will have a greater propensity to
use it because of what they saw growing
up we're not using that data to let them
off the hook that doesn't let any
individual off the hook but it does say
we might need trauma support programs we
might need different ways we talk about
violence if we're working in settings as
we do in Brazil for example where forty
percent of young people say they have
seen their mother experience violence
from a man that means we need in
addition to some broad social norm
change we also need some psychosocial
support that acknowledges the specific
risk that those individuals face and
then out and then the last point
Catherine that you brought up on scale
is precisely that I mean we've done a
lot of very thoughtful and well
evaluated small scale interventions we
may reach 250 maybe 2,000 but really the
issue is how do we go to a much bigger
scale if this is something that affects
one-third of the world's women obviously
something that kind of reaches seven
hundred two thousand five thousand at a
time will not do it so how do we take
these things to scale well one I think
is to build on the success of what we've
done in the women's rights field in the
last 30 years we've gotten girls into
school we now have more children around
the world finishing primary school than
ever before that sets up the school
was a tremendous important site for
doing gender equality education
sexuality education comprehensive
sexuality education that includes
messages and discussions around
gender-based violence women's economic
empowerment microcredit programs now
reach upwards of 125 million women
around the world they have limitations
of course but a tremendous space to
reach partners to reach households on
violence to be a screening place women's
access to maternal health and our
success around HIV in terms of getting
testing particularly women getting
testing we've got tremendous
opportunities to screen and to provide
prevention in ways that we may not have
had 20 years before so I think if we
really believe in that scale that we're
talking about how do we use these
successes of development of the last 30
40 years with all the challenges those
bring capacity staffing training of
staff but really to think in big ways to
take ahead the prevention and then the
last point I think we also have to be
thoughtful that ending violence doesn't
mean that we've achieved gender equality
it's a huge step toward it but all the
forms of structural violence and
inequality that women face every day
whether it's the caregiving burden
whether it's the pay that we just talked
about whether it's access to leadership
positions whether it's even when there's
not violence men's control of household
income says that we're not done so let's
not assume that just because men may not
be as violent in one given setting in
terms of their use of physical violence
that equality is still kind of ways off
and we need men to be part of all those
discussions as well that's kind of a big
agenda I think I should stop there for
the moment come for some more questions
what do you have questions from the
audience but maybe I will allow dr.
number do you want to ask a quick
question but it has to be quick is we
want questions from the audience yes
absolutely and I'm the moderator I will
do as you say so um I'm an
anthropologist of Central Africa an area
that seemed truly unfortunate if not
tragic levels of armed violence in
recent decades and it strikes me that
these places that are experiencing armed
violence there are places where we see
some of the biggest problems with gender
violence and they also present a lot of
unique and very difficult challenges and
so I'm curious to hear you know what
strategies have you
found successful for working on gender
violence in places that are undergoing
armed conflict I mean in places such as
centrally maybe that's probably DRC for
instance in a case in point in going
back to the topic global intervention
the turning of the curve in the DRC was
by and large enabled by the extent to
which everybody in every corner of the
world cares about this issue made DRC a
forecast from the United Nations to
church groups to civil society to
women's movement we all supported the
women of the DRC and we helped the
government they accountable for tanning
in the corner we scaled up also a legal
interventions when they were successful
prosecutions of perpetrators that helped
to have to detail also when we looked at
reparations led to whole communities
including site the healing of
communities in making sure that you were
able to bring communities together to
fight together that you addressed
education and made sure that both girls
and boys state at school and that the
teacher took some responsibility to look
after the interests of the children when
it to tells with trained also to
identify and to see when it children are
experiencing trauma so again it took
it's a myriad of intervention and it's
still not perfect I'm actually going
there next week it's still not perfect
that is why we could keep going it's
important to to to to turn the situation
around it but it's obviously much better
than it was five 5 10 years 10 years ago
so questions from the audience you can
now speak very loudly or microphones are
going to appear very close to you I will
take two
three questions at the same time
Priyanka would you give I don't in any
way wanted I don't in any way want to
Tripoli trivialize what the speaker is
doing I think it's very admirable but
I'm just curious um were you ever it did
you base your career choice on any
personal experience you mean the in
relation to violence yes well I lived
under apartheid that was a violent
system no opposite of a potato is pretty
personal because you got incarcerated
beaten up by police and so basically
being arrested I have an experienced
domestic violence but appetit violence
was quite traumatic yes dr. Barker you
touched on this a little bit in your
comments but it seems to me that social
norms are very important it's it seems
to me that social norms are very
important contributor to violence and i
would think that legislation would have
very limited impact if not accompanied
by social norms change and i was
wondering what you or any of the other
panelists thought concerning is social
norms something that should just be left
to change organically or their concrete
actions and steps that we can take to
change social norms and cultures that
promote or support violence against
women um you answered your question and
i'll respond out and I'll just echo that
absolutely I don't think we can just
rely on laws and that's why I did bring
up the example of the number of
countries that have laws on the books
but the norm hasn't changed and I think
it's both the general public but also
those who are responsible as Duty
bearers to implement those laws and we
do have evidence that whether the
community level or the level of a school
or a workplace that well-designed social
norm campaigns can actually change
including norms around sexual assault on
campus some of these that are well
done that don't demonize men in general
but that play into men who already
questioned some of the norms that
question the belief that while everybody
is doing it when in fact research shows
that it's often a small minority but
those minority kind of keep the others
quiet because they're seen as the men
that you don't want to question so
whether at the campus level or a dorm
level or a school level or on there's
some evidence that the ad council adds
that features without violence did in
the US have also led to changes in
social norms so we know they can work I
mean again I think it's not social norms
or laws but it's how do we do both of
them at the same time and do them well
um I was wondering in terms of making
legislation are there sees me certain
environments that are more conducive to
legislation making maybe post-conflict
are having more women involved in female
quotas in the parliament does that
affect the type of laws that are
presented and passed and potentially
implemented is in a in a in a crisis
sometimes there's a big opportunity to
bring about big changes when there's a
negotiation of a peace agreement if all
things are equal that's when you get
far-reaching changes and we've seen that
post-conflict countries in some ways are
the countries that have for instance
involved the highest number of women in
decision making because that sometimes
become part of a piss package for
instance I think of a or also even
addressing some of the issues that
impact on women if I think of Columbia
right now the negotiations that have
been ongoing there and the strong rule
that has been played by women if women
were not part of that process men would
have agreed that a sexual violence is
off limits or perpetrators on both sides
must be forgiven women were there they
insisted on it and reparations in the
healing that is required for women and
healing of whole communities and there
is likely to bring about better
reconciliation in the community a 44 in
for a longer period of time and limit
the disruption of violence in again if I
think for instance my own parts of the
world where they think about South
Africa Namibia Mozambique the violence
they was PT tense Mozambique the war was
quite intense Angola and so on women
were actively involved also in the
negotiations and the contribution has
been said the women as they called us in
keeping the peace in the post-conflict
and we just did a study which we
released about a month a month ago in an
optimal in October where we are
reviewing the 15 years of implementing
resolution 1325 on women peace and
security in that study it comes out
clearly that in those peace negotiations
where women were very active those
countries have been able to hold longer
Liberia is there isn't is an example
even got themselves a woman president is
so to say and therefore we are able to
then use that experience in every
conflict but sadly though the buy-in by
neck by countries that support
negotiation is not as good as it needs
to be we find that you while you cannot
rely on the fighting parties to be the
most gender sensitive it's always a
beginning Badman forgiving another bad
man in front of TV when you bring in
women you take away that women are
concerned about ending the conflict
about humanitarian support and access
about rebuilding in the infrastructure
about education about plowing the fields
again about food about clinics and those
are the things that actually rebuild a
society so I don't know if I answers
your question
my question is on religious states and
communities in general that sort of
promote practices and laws that arm are
questionable and dehumanize women has
there been any progress in that regard
and what strategies are you looking at
is for you well it's it's a mixed bag
really it's it's what is even more
troubling right now is the fact that in
those intense conflict areas it's not
states that are fighting is non-state
actors who do not respect any Rome
Statute you cannot what can you
negotiate with Isis Opaka haram they are
determined to do everything in the most
outrageous in way so in those situations
you find that the extent to which the
women's rights are violated and the
trauma that comes with it is actually
quite deep anyway are therefore unable
to see the progress that would come
about in a situation where you referred
to piece it was negotiated in the
agreement and whole society is trying to
live up to a post-conflict and to enter
into implement so in in in those in
those situations where these that's kind
of violence it you cannot see a lot of
violence however where you do not have a
violent conflict there is a chance of
being able to work systematically to
collaborate to hold politicians
accountable to work with education and
you we begin to see even the change of a
culture for instance Jordan and honor
killing at some point on a killing in
that country was very common brothers
fathers could kill
a girl up sista a mother for being in a
relationship with someone that the
family disapproved of a because it's a
it's a it's not a failed state it's a
it's a proper country we are actually
seeing that that practice in that
country is slowly a you know diminishing
even in a country like Egypt who still
has all kinds of problems the fact that
it's some kind of Fatima no not a
democratic what do you call youtubed
anyway but even in Egypt we are actually
seeing that we make able to make inroads
and were able to turn around for
instance some of the extreme violations
that we experience in Egypt just in the
short time when the Muslim Brotherhood
in power Egypt was taken like you know I
don't know how many decades back just
the kind of unleashing of violence
against women and practices Egyptians
wanted a proper democracy we've ended up
with a soldier ruling them but in some
ways the women in the new constitution
have gained a lot of possibilities for
them to assert some rights and we are
using those rights and spaces to end
child marriages to make sure that women
can have IDs to remove laws that stop
women from doing some works it's a very
make a picture
could you speak to some of the ways that
certain narratives of sexual violence
against women particularly African
nations can have consequences that are
actually can't contradictory to their
aims for example we know that there's a
lot of focus in the DRC for example on
alleviating sexual violence but there
has been such a narrow focus by the
international community that continues
to perpetuate to perpetuate this framing
of African women as sexual victims alone
and not elevating or supporting their
agency or supporting them in other ways
such as an education and economic
empowerment that can more holistically
elevate the experience of women in the
nation and for example a few years ago
there was a rebel militia that
purposefully ordered the mass rapes of a
village because they knew they had
leverage in this because the
international community was only
focusing on sexual violence against
women and in that way it sort of
counterproductive ly continue to
perpetuate this violence because the
focus was very narrow and not holistic
and how it worked to work within the
community in terms of building social
norms legally and other aspects of
change that weren't so that weren't so
fragile in the way that they actually
helped women on the ground I think
probably if you had what both myself and
gary with was saying we do not look just
at the physical violence as a problem
it's a number of things it's the
customary law it's education it's
poverty it's the laws you have got to
fight all of these things at the same
time for change to be systemic and to be
a long-lasting a in some countries
because sexual violence is so brutal
it's difficult to ignore it but just
focusing on it alone does not do it in
any case in many of the countries even
where you have got peacekeepers working
in
in those countries what the peacekeeping
forces is able to do is a fraction of
what needs to change in that country
they can derail some attacks offer
sexual violence nature they can create
barriers between the attackers and the
community but women are actually being
beaten up inside their own homes by
their own partners where the Peacekeeper
is not inside the house when the girls
are not at school you already take away
the future of those girls so and that is
why I think in the UN you've got a
specialist who works on sexual violence
because of its nature but us as you and
women we work on all issues work on
leadership work on human rights we work
on education we work on economic
empowerment because we see that as a
package that needs judge so I think you
answered your own question in a way
comment just I think it's a really
important point of some of the
phenomenon around DRC because on the one
hand if there was a global success story
that attention was focused in action has
come to bear the UN attention and funds
that are going in to make eastern DRC
more stable and less conflict prone are
important but I think you're absolutely
right there was a bit of a perverse
equation that started to happen that and
we've carried out a household survey and
do ongoing work in and around Goma and
one of the things that comes out quite
clearly is yes there's high rates of
conflict related sexual violence about
one in four women have experienced it as
about one in ten men but there's also
about sixty percent of households women
have experienced violence from the male
partner including marital rape about a
third of children experience some form
of sexual violence growing up about
two-thirds of households displaced
because of conflict but most of the
programming good intention initially but
what really was not looking at the
holistic needs that I think you bring up
and where it becomes really perverse is
where donors kind of look and hear that
data but continuing to offer kind of
weird we only came here to do this one
of the
the providers of medical and
psychosocial support to women he'll
Africa in Goma says that now the main
reason that it does fish till repair
surgery is not the sexual violence
related but because of undernourished
team adolescent mothers so basically the
causes which is much more a structural
problem that you can't you can't find a
single perpetrator it's called poverty
and inequality it's called years of a
you know colonial history it's called we
know all the things that it's called but
those are much more intractable problems
that the international donor community
can't resolve in sort of one edict or
one cycle of troops going in under the
minus schoo arrangement so I think it's
a really good point and we do need to
feel that we've got the space to be more
critical about it because we really are
in DRC and some other places doing it to
service to women by only kind of looking
at them as victims I think that's a key
point so please keep bringing that up
because it does need to be brought up
well I think in an important point here
to make is that there is no country that
has achieved gender equality in the
world and we are trying to put some
countries under pressure that have got
the best possible conditions to break
the mold to show that gender equality is
attainable and and I can see you I can
see me from thinking she must be crazy
but we have got to be optimistic so part
of he for she is to put countries under
pressure leaders in particular who are
mostly men to actually embrace a gender
equality and to do something about it
including aiming to help the country
achieve gender equality here for she is
a campaign in which we are crowdsourcing
the participation of man you register
online can do Daniel can you click on it
can click on the unit different
countries and when you register it tells
us how many men in that particular
country have registered is he for she
and we expect those men to go to
to then actively participate in in
creative activities that's a address
gender college you can decide for
yourself for instance a nail what you
want to focus in but those and in a
union universities that are amongst the
universities that have registered to be
here for [ __ ] one of the things they
have to do is to address is
significantly the issue of violence
against women the issue of a
representation of women in STEM for
instance an errand which I hear you are
doing not too badly compared to other
universities here but also the presence
of men in social sciences the seniority
of women in faculty and so on and so on
so we sign an agreement with the
University and we rise and fall together
to try and address those issues in
countries for instance in Finland I mean
in Iceland which is a country with the
highest rating for gender equality we
have asked them to aim to be the first
country to attain gender equality before
the end of the sustainable development
goals they have a per capita the highest
number of men who have registered but
also a programme of action to achieve to
attain gender equality we also sign up
heads of private sector and prides of
private sector they must change their
quality I mean the the purchases in
their company fest but also they must
contribute to us an economy that will
attain equal pay equal representation of
women in decent jobs and and and and so
on so that is the he for she campaign
which I hope that they will get to more
people here in able to sign up to and
boost the numbers of your different
countries the number of men that are
actively participating thank you very
much now because it's one o'clock i'm
going to close this session before you
go I want to tell you they are
sandwiches and reception upstairs if you
would want to come and have close
conversation with our executive director
and dr. Barker for instance I want to
thank he before I thank my panelists I
want to thank the audience for coming
because as we've know we are a
generation that can leverage change we
can promote a culture of respect we can
embrace gender equality and
we have very clear goals to do so and so
thank you very much dr. Moran will in
buca because you've given us an example
an example of of that global leadership
of the path to follow by 2030 thank you
very much indeed for coming and thank
you for